I have to ask you about the whole
sterling scandal it's it's obviously a
big national story and we're we're here
in Los Angeles and everyone's been
talking about it at first it seemed
everybody well this problem solved the
NBA is forcing sterling out he can no
longer be an owner of the Clippers right
but now it's all dawning on everyone
that this is going to be a long probably
legal process is that what you think
it's going to be well yes I mean I've
known the guy since 81 he would sue over
a bowl of soup have you ever met this
guy now you just want to shower in
Listerine as soon as you've met the guy
what what is it about him I don't know
what he's like personally I mean I've
seen the pictures of him where he's one
of my best friend
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm sorry he and Donald are very tight
maybe before you got to LA but he would
have these he sued mistresses before and
during the trial he talked about where
they had sex and how great it was they
tried to sue him when he first moved the
team from San Diego to LA without
permission you know I did this story
before marge schott of the Cincinnati
Reds showed me a Nazi armband and she
insulted blacks and Asians she's really
I mean sterling is really just marge
schott with larger breasts right right
and it took it took her it took us two
years to get her out of the league and
it'll take this guy it's gonna really
it's gonna take that long so this this
talk of boy the players aren't gonna
boycott ya that's why there was a rumor
last week that players would boycott
this season if he wasn't out you think
that's not that's ridiculous was
supposedly talking about a boycott but
then the guy took it back there's no way
these guys have contracts and sterling
will sue for years and years and years
and if that doesn't work he'll put the
whole thing in divorce court and that
won't ever come out so this could be ten
years before this is settled right sorry
so you've spent time you said you spent
a lot of time with sterling in not a lot
of time I said when you shake his hand
you really just want to you know die
he's just he's just a berry I gotta go
probably so much you'll sit ya know when
I came up with the title Tiger meat my
sister it comes from this this list I
have in my computer of sentences that
have never been uttered in the history
of the English language right like Shaq
Shaq you shoot the technical right
Donald Sterling's coming to my Kwanzaa
party and Tiger meet my sister that's
not gonna happen not gonna happen I
don't know how he likes that title but I
got here I'm sure he clearly yeah
clearly you don't carry twenty-minute
ran oh he's he's the Grinch who stole
Christmas what do I care
Tiger likes to ride into Whoville and
take away that Christmas trees